most actors toil away in obscurity for
years waiting for the chance to finally
burst into the limelight not every big
break however is as satisfying as it
seems at the start
sometimes a star gets fed up with their
role then again sometimes actors just
want to see their characters bite the
dust
in the most epic way possible what more
can an actor hope for but a memorable
on-screen death
Harrison Ford Star Wars few roles are
more associated with Harrison Ford than
the one that started it all han Solo
despite the fact that the role launched
his blockbuster career Ford initially
wanted George Lucas to kill solo off
during Return of the Jedi
he felt that solo sacrifice would lend
emotional weight to the story and I
thought that the best utility of the
character would be for him to sacrifice
himself to a high ideal but according to
Ford
Lucas was reluctant to put a dent in Han
Solo action figure sales so he kept solo
alive that let the scoundrel build a
family with Leia within the Star Wars
universe meanwhile those of us stuck in
the real crappier universe got 40 years
of Han Solo action figures why did you
do it he can't trick me huh I had no
choice Pacific anyway in retirement Rin
of course forgot his wish in 2015 the
force awakens
going off to that great big moisture
farm in the sky samuel l.jackson deep
blue sea deep blue sea is one of those
movies that came together in the right
place at the right time if it hadn't hit
right before the flood of a giant
monster schlock fest tearing up the
sci-fi channel in the early 2000s
director Renny Harlin's
goofy monster romp probably wouldn't
have made it onto the big screen now
it's a guilty pleasure chock-full of
sharks and truly poetic dialogue
my bird
Oh
when Harlan initially contacted actor
samuel l.jackson he offered jackson the
role that ended up going to LL Cool J
Sherman preacher Dudley Jackson declined
so Harlan created the character of
Russell Franklin specifically for him as
soon as he read Franklin's death scene
Jackson was on board according to the
DVD commentary the actor relished the
opportunity to die in dramatic horror
movie fashion saying quote I've done a
lot of different things in movies but
nothing like what happens to me in this
one and float his character's death
truly is one of the most memorable in
recent cinematic history as well as
something of a jab at the cinematic
trove of blowhard heroic speeches
Leonard Nimoy Star Trek to Wrath of Khan
few characters are more widely
recognized than Leonard Nimoy's Spock
starting with the original Star Trek
series Spock has had a story sci-fi
career appearing on episodes of the next
generation as well as eight Star Trek
movies from Star Trek the motion picture
all the way to star trek into darkness
however the half-human half-vulcan run
nearly ended before his cinematic
journey really started after the first
Trek film Nimoy wanted to set aside the
role indefinitely if not permanently to
convince Nimoy to sign on for Wrath of
Khan paramount producer Harv Bennett and
screenwriter Jack Bauer's offer the
actor a juicy death sequence ironically
it was Spock's death that actually kept
Nimoy in the Star Trek universe
Nimoy enjoyed his last hurrah as Foxx so
much that he decided to come back for
further installments and even directed
Star Trek 3 the search for Spock and
Star Trek for the voyage home Isaac
Hayes South Park no one can deny the
power of chef for nine seasons Isaac
Hayes rich baritone made the lusty
school lunch prepper into one of the
show's breakout characters but South
Park's unique brand of satire was a
little too far for his taste in 2000
sides the actor and musician a
Scientologist was reportedly offended by
their critique of the controversial
religious sect in the episode trapped in
the closet which mocked the religions
biggest names such as Tom Cruise and
John Travolta as well as the group's
unusual views
what's going on Tom Cruise won't come
out of the closet what just leave me
alone well we can't leave you alone
because you won't come out of the closet
the episode was apparently the straw
that broke a is back because the
musician told stone and Parker he wanted
out of his contract due to South Park's
growing insensitivity towards personal
spiritual beliefs the character met a
fittingly over-the-top and on the show
as chef was killed after being struck by
lightning impaled on a branch and
attacked by a mountain lion and a bear
it was a classically South Park end to a
classic character oh my god they killed
chef Dean Norris Breaking Bad Breaking
Bad is one of those shows that came out
of nowhere and blew everybody away
thanks in no small part to Bryan
Cranston's performance as Walter White
a guy opens historian gets shot you
thinking out of me no I am the one who
knocks aside from its intriguing premise
and tightly coiled suspense
Michelle's true heart came from a host
of offbeat characters that gave the
morally grey dramedy a rabid fan base of
those d norris's Hank Schrader rapidly
became a fan favorite as the series
progressed to its vince and final season
though norris's Betsy and Craig grew and
acting gigs abounded in order to
potentially start the next phase of his
career the actor asked the producers if
they could take out his character
halfway through the last season to which
they replied we kind of need you for the
last eight episodes we've been building
that out for the last five years in
light of the series shocking conclusion
Norris was ultimately glad they
convinced him to stay so are the show's
fans sophie Turner Game of Thrones yes
it's true Sansa Stark is still alive and
kicking on Game of Thrones at least as
of the making of this video but sophie
Turner isn't just ready for her
character to die she's actively seeking
it out as a member of the powerful stark
clan Sansa grew from a misty eyed tween
into a resilient young heiress right
before our eyes
sophie Turner's already moving in a new
direction as Jean Grey in the x-men
universe among other film roles and the
actress has expressed her desire for the
eldest stark daughter to follow in her
family's footsteps in an interview
Turner joke if you're on Game of Thrones
and you don't have a cool death scene
then what's the point
pink that's the truth fortunately for
Sansa the HBO juggernaut is preparing to
take his final bow so she may get her
wish after all at the same time writer
George RR Martin's final books have yet
to arrive on store shelves so we don't
have any official word on the fate of
Miss Stark assuming the series stays
remotely close to the books from here on
out anyway when it comes to Game of
Thrones
well Union Nations Sean Bean Lord of the
Rings the Fellowship of the Ring
reintroduced JRR Tolkien's classic
fantasy series to the general public in
a major way and a lot of the film beauty
came from the epic filming locations in
the mountains of New Zealand the problem
was Sean Bean who played Boromir
like flying when he realized that Peter
Jackson intended to shoot extensively on
remote rocky locales around New Zealand
he decided to get there the
old-fashioned way
and then they dropped me off there and
I'd sort of hike another after mile you
know how just because I did want to get
on the year Helen company basically bean
would put on his Boromir costume and
trek up the mountain on foot to reach
the set as many times that the actor has
died on screen he said that the death of
Boromir in fellowship was easily his
favourite but come on it's got to be
gold night everyone knows it
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love still